at moments of sorrow and exhaustion it's
only too easy to look back over the
years and feel that our lives have in
essence being meaningless we take stock
of just how much has gone wrong
how many errors they've beat how many
unfulfilled plans and frustrated dreams
we've had we may feel like the
distraught damned Macbeth who on
learning of his wife's death
exclaims at a pitch of agony that man is
a cursed creature who struts and frets
his hour upon the stage and then is
heard no more life is a tale told by an
idiot full of sound and fury signifying
nothing no life can avoid an
intermittently high degree of sound and
fury but the question is whether it must
also ultimately signify nothing as
Macbeth
lines hint this will depend on who is
telling it in the hands of Shakespeare's
bracingly turned idiot the story of a
life may well turn into unintelligible
and dispiriting gibberish but with
sufficient compassion and insight we may
equally be able to make something
different and a great deal more
meaningful and redemptive out of the
same material the difference between
despair and hope is just a different way
of telling stories from the same set of
facts only a small number of us ever
self-consciously write our
autobiographies it's a task we associate
with celebrities and the very old but it
is in the background a universal
activity we may not be publishing our
stories but we are writing them in our
minds nevertheless every day finds us
weaving a story about who we are where
we're going and why events happened as
they did many of us are strikingly harsh
narrator's of these life stories we hint
to ourselves
we've been morons from the beginning
we've stuffed up big time it's been one
disaster after another that's how we go
about narrating especially late at night
when our reserves of optimism run dry
and the demons return yet there is
nothing necessary about our
self-flagellating methods of narration
there could always be ways of telling
very different far kinder and more
balanced stories from the same set of
facts you could give you a life story
too Dostoevsky Proust or Jesus and come
out with a rather bearable moving tender
and Noble story good by which is meant
fair-minded and judicious narrators know
that lives can be meaningful even when
they involve a lot of failure and
humiliation mistakes don't have to be
absurd they can be signs of how little
information we have on which to base the
most consequential decisions messing up
isn't a sign of evil it's evidence of
what we're up against not all the
disasters are wasted anyway maybe we
spent a decade not quite knowing what we
wanted to do with ourselves
professionally maybe we went through a
succession of failed relationships that
left us confused and hurt a lot of
people but these experiences weren't
meaningless because they were necessary
to later development and maturity we
needed the career crisis to understand
our working identities we had to fail at
love to fathom our hearts no one gets
anywhere important in just one go we
have to forgive ourselves the horrors of
our first drafts the good storyteller
recognizes contrary to certain
impressions that the central character
of a story isn't always responsible for
every disaster or triumph we're never
the sole authors of everything that
happens to us sometimes it really will
be the economy our parents the
government our enemies or simply the
tragic dimensions of human existence
that are to blame good narrators don't
always move a personal
every day we are induced in a rate a bit
more of our life story to ourselves we
explain why there's pain why we forgot
to seize a chance and maybe why we are
in an unhappy situation but all this
doesn't need to be a tale told by an
idiot signifying nothing it can be a
tale told by a kind intelligent soul
signifying rather a lot like almost
every life story it is in truth a tale
of a well-intentioned flawed partially
blind self deceived but ultimately
dignified and quite good human being
struggling against enormous odds
sometimes on a good day
succeeding just a little in a few areas
at the school of life we believe in
developing emotional intelligence to
that end we've also created a whole
range of products to support that growth
find out more at the link on the screen
now